i guess what i'm trying to say okay
sorry
hello
oh my gosh it's happening nationwide a
second high school has now closed should
schools reopen
first you can't have one basic answer
across the country because we have so
much variability
it cannot be done unsafely or we'll be
right back where we started
i just feel like that's the risk some of
our seniors are willing to take to have
our senior year
my name is charlie i'm going into my
senior year and i'm from los angeles
california
my name is nyla i live in philadelphia
pennsylvania and i am going to be
hi my name is laura rose i'm from the
greater boston area massachusetts
and i'm going to be a sophomore i'm
sophie i live in omaha nebraska and i'm
going to be a sophomore in high school
my name is jacob i live in fountain
hills michigan and i'm going into my
junior year with my school
hi i'm vanessa i am 17 years old and i
live in florida
i'm hannah i'm going into my senior year
and i'm in spokane washington
tick tock is life
three two one
i used to spend so much time on tick
tock but
it got to a point where it became a
problem i sometimes spent four hours
on tick-tock just like scrolling for me
it's like clearly a problem but i say
like roll with it
like the enjoyment that i get out of
tick-tock is like so immense like i
don't know what i do with my six
extra hours i never even like got
tick-tock or
had tick-tock i just don't really get it
honestly it really depends on like what
content you watch
once you get past the skinny hot girls
dancing like commentary tick tock
i mean those tick tocks end up
everywhere and those references slip
in it's definitely not something that
you can ignore because it's so
fair i want my school to go back
to in-person learning three
two one
i live in florida and it's one of the
worst days when it comes to sorna virus
and everyone is doing whatever they want
you're not ready
right now to go back to sleep i'm a
senior this year and
i just i love school so i really really
want to go back
but i definitely don't want to go back
at the risk of like
spreading covet i'm actually like really
happy with my school's plans because we
have like four
options so that if you don't feel
comfortable going back to school you
have
the option to not go back to school i
really do
would want to go back to school but at
the same time
i have to commute to school yeah i agree
with you charlie
i want to go back but i have to take
three buses
public transportation i'm not for that
right now the hybrid schedule
half will go on monday tuesday the other
half will go in wednesday thursday
everyone's home friday
for me the plan is unacceptable because
what about the kids who aren't going in
like what do we do
i feel like right now online school
isn't being
part of the solution it's almost just
like a punishment for like
the government not taking enough steps i
live in nebraska and we were
like the last city out of the biggest
like 100 cities to like get a mass
mandate they said we were going to go
back and then
like a week before school started they
like completely changed their mind
which in my opinion was like a good
thing to do because like our numbers
are just like keep going up the schools
are acting like they know what's
happening but like deep down like
it's like clear that they have no clue
either yeah i
totally agree because the teachers union
is so strong where i'm from
the teachers wanting to stay home is
overpowering the students needs they
gave us the first month off to
prepare but then that only resulted in
them throwing us busy work for the rest
of the two months
you need to adapt to the medium and
serve your students i don't care what
that happens
i mean i do agree with that at the same
time the teachers are also
under an enormous amount of stress i
definitely want to go back but
having seen firsthand how china dealt
with it it's like coming back to the us
infection rate is incredibly high
how we haven't tested a fifth of the
people to me it's too scary to even
comprehend
if every single kid went back to school
i have missed out
on major life milestones because of the
pandemic
three two one
the summer after your junior year before
your senior year is the one that's most
important that colleges are going to
look at
i've tried so hard to like get a job or
volunteer
i can't and it's so frustrating because
i do
track and gymnastics and like captains
on both those teams super super excited
for me to be a captain
just like really turned everything
upside down it kind of sucks
i moved from my country about three
years ago
i was a lot of stuff behind everyone
else i literally learned about college
application
last year this year i was gonna do all
those things that people started doing
freshman year but because of the
pandemic
was everything got cancelled and i was
very sad i felt like
i was even more step behind everyone
else i'm just curious
where you're from oh i'm from venezuela
oh
how is that well for me when i was
living there the lie
would just not work no water or not good
internet connection and they are doing
um online school so it's a mess
but i'm glad i'm here first of all
you're so brave for like
leaving your country i'm a first
generation and my family had to go
through something similar across you
you're the best so the main thing i
missed out on
was the musical which was crushing
because i've been wanting to be in it
since
first grade once i actually thought
about it i was actually kind of
miserable
at school um i was always the black
sheep of my grave
so to not get like weird stares is like
oh my god i'm actually a person who
matters it's actually been quite good
for my mental health which i wasn't
expecting
i have experienced mental health issues
due to the pandemic
three two one
this pandemic was extremely damaging
to my mental health on so many different
levels when black lives matter movement
was like hitting headlines again
um because of the death of george floyd
it was very uncomfortable for me because
i had people like dming me personally
like
questions oh gosh it makes me cringe
what can i do
how can i be a better person i don't
understand what's going on
and i was like i understand that because
you know some people just don't truly
know what's going on in the world
but being like the little girl i am like
i didn't know how to explain to people
why my life matters and then not to
mention with my school
i was asked like how do we help make our
students of color more comfortable
i was just like shouldn't i already be
comfortable like i feel like it should
be a space for everyone you shouldn't
have to like accommodate to me
and then that moment like i realized
that some people who claim to be my
friends weren't
they saw um the black lives matter
movement more as like a trend so i was
like kind of telling everyone please
just give me some space i'm really
overwhelmed i don't know how to process
this
like as teenagers like i feel like we
shouldn't have to have like a care in
the world
but it almost feels as if so much stuff
is being like shoved
at us that it's like we don't know how
to deal with this and it feels like we
have to deal with this like way sooner
than we should
like have to deal with this my country
is basically a bubble
you don't realize you are in that bubble
until you get out of that
they are worried for other things that
thankfully we don't have to worry about
like if you're safe or
if you're going to eat
something tomorrow so when i came here i
realized teenagers have
more time and more rights
and platforms to voice what they want to
say
a lot of people are watching them and
listen to them
while in my country just cannot
do that and that's why i feel like this
quarantine is maybe taking us
out of that and sort of opening our eyes
like
20 20 20 20 vision like that's what i
think of we're sort of realizing that
we aren't going to like stick through
with this system
and we really need to be like living our
lives at some point
i think the us is handling the pandemic
properly three two
one
hell no i'm sorry i strongly disagree
no not at all the government failed
their class you should be kicked out of
the classroom
like we need a refresher here our state
is practically
just a cornfield people think that like
the world doesn't like reach us exactly
a week ago got a mask mandate like
finally in my city
it's not being enforced like at all like
our own like governor
is against it now more than ever like
change
needs to happen and that change can
happen
november 3rd everybody go out and vote
yeah they basically did everything that
they could wrong
first after that the politicians decide
what uh motion should we pass and what
shouldn't be
and then they let it go down to the
local and state levels and so you can't
make a uniform decision
and thirdly it's the people themselves
who are like
you know what my right is i don't have
to wear a mask so i'm not gonna wear it
and then for people in china my friends
were like what in the world are they
thinking are they out of their
minds and for them it's like this is
this is the pinnacle of
americans like from the outside world
this is america at its
best aka it's worse i noticed that we're
holding australia and new zealand on
such a pedestal however
i get a little fishy because they have
crazy curfews and
they're installing cameras to track
their citizens like it's extremely
important to protect people
but like the people who question things
they do have a point like
how much of our personal freedom are we
going to sacrifice for this virus
what rights am i willing to have
stripped away throughout history when
rights are taken away they don't
typically come back
i mean you can practice social
distancing
110 correct and have all of your likes
you can still
talk on social media right like no
nobody's like large gatherings
well dude it's a pandemic i mean you're
sort of like that's
exactly what you're not supposed to do i
think there's levels to it though
i think it's very fair that like there
are certain levels and degrees into
which
it's like oh well that's like a little
aggressive
one of the reasons why america has
struggled so much with mandates and
everything
is that people believe so strongly in
the idea of personal freedom
they don't understand that in order to
have personal freedom in order to live
in a society you have to give up other
regions
the pandemic has affected my future
plans
three two one
before when i was younger i was like i'm
gonna go to usc film school and i'm
gonna become the film director and i was
just like that's my goal
but i don't really know how what's gonna
happen after high school
but i'm also have faith that whatever
happens i'll be happy with
and then i just found out recently that
like usc is handing out free tuition and
i actually may have an opportunity if i
get in
to pursue that i have no clue what i
want to do with my life
which is so hard for me because growing
up like i wanted to be a singer i want
to be an actress and i want to be a
criminal justice defense attorney
i have no clue where i want to go
but i do believe it means that's
manifestation
yeah manifesting i believe in
manifestation so
if i know that i'm going to end up good
i'm look like i'm gonna be great it's
just that i don't know what i'm gonna be
breaking yet and i'm okay with it i'm
okay go
off snaps for that very well said
very well said that is it for our
conversation
thank you guys so much it was so nice
talking to you all
awesome should we all chat like our
instagram handles
yes that would be yeah um mine is so
long i hate it
you can change it you know oh wait